it's been five years since a magnitude
7.8 earthquake struck parts of Nepal
sannomiya sakis home collapsed in the
quake tired of living in a temporary
shelter her family is rebuilding their
house in boom mati near the capital
Katmandu where eight hundred homes were
destroyed and seven people died many of
our neighbors have left their temporary
shelters we felt alone so we decided to
rebuild our house and move the 16th
century town is a draw for visitors
contributing significantly to its
tourism economy it is home to the temple
of Mahindra not where Kathmandu valleys
farmers pray for rain and a good harvest
the temple collapsed during the
earthquake reconstruction has been slow
some community concerns and differences
over conservation efforts have delayed
reconstruction of the temple we have
formed a local committee to move work
forward Nepal's national reconstruction
Authority says more than 80 percent of
homes and public infrastructure damaged
in the quake have been rebuilt across
the country in boom mati
the number is significantly lower those
behind the reconstruction effort are
hopeful of progress cigars at the time
about 400 homes have been reconstructed
and in the next one to two years we
expect more people to move out from
temporary shelters at the rebuild their
houses local officials say 50 percent of
reconstruction is complete but the
remaining work may take longer is a
farming community people on land but
very few people have cast our resources
to rebuild their homes so the
construction may take up to 8 to 10
years until we construction is complete
many families here will continue to live
in temporary shelters from ether limbo
al Jazeera Katmandu